here with us. If you would turn turn in your Bibles to Psalm 16. That's that's our
text for this morning and I will go ahead and read it. Psalm 16. Preserve me, O God,
for in you I take refuge. I say to the Lord, You are my Lord. I have no good
apart from You. As for the saints in the land, they are the excellent ones
in whom is all my delight. The sorrows of those who run after another God shall
multiply. Their drink offerings of blood I will not pour out or take their names on
my lips. The Lord is my chosen portion and my cup. You hold my lot. The lines have
fallen for me in pleasant places. Indeed, I have a beautiful inheritance. I
bless the Lord who gives me counsel. In the night also my heart instructs me. I've
set the Lord always before me because He is at my right hand. I shall not be
shaken. Therefore my heart is glad and my whole being rejoices. My flesh also
dwells secure. For you will not abandon my soul to shield or let your
holy one see corruption. You make known to me the path of life. In your presence
there is fullness of joy. At your right hand are pleasures forevermore. Pray with
me one more time.
Fathers, as we open your word, we just ask that you would open the eyes of
our heart. Enlighten us that we may see and behold glorious things from
your word, not the words of a mere mortal man broken and sinful, but your
perfect, unblemished words. Would you use this to change us and once again help
us behold the glory of Jesus Christ? For it's in Jesus' name we pray. Amen.
So I've always been a movie guy, but growing up watched a ton more movies.
And so in the early 90s there was a movie called City Slickers. I doubt there's
many people in here who have seen that. It starred Billy Crystal. I'm not
necessarily recommending the movie because it was PG-13 and it was early
90s version of PG-13, which is a little debatable. Nonetheless I liked the
movie then. And Billy Crystal plays this character who's this big city
advertising executive, but he's burned out. He's exhausted by life, just
everything being thrown at him. He's depressed by how fast his life has
flown by. And yet I look at it, he was only 39. I'm like, you're just a
youngster, you know, from my perspective. But at any rate, he's depressed. And it
comes to the point where his wife says, you are miserable. You need to just
go away for a couple of weeks and find your smile. So he and a couple of his
buddies sign up for this two-week rugged cattle drive out west. And it's
during that cattle drive there's a scene that I love, because there's this
rough and tough cowboy played by Jack Palance, who you've probably seen in
Western movies. He's just that typical gritty, rough cowboy. But there's a
scene there where he tells him, you city folks worry about too much bleep. I'll
say stuff. But then he goes on to tell him the secret to life is one thing. He
holds up his finger. He says one thing. And so Billy Crystal's character, he's
got to know what that is. And he asks him and he says, I'm not going to
tell you. That's for you to figure out. And so he spends the rest of the
cattle drive and the rest of the movie trying to figure it out. Isn't
that kind of like how life is? We're so busy sometimes. We got so much thrown
at us. Do we really know what that one thing is? Sociologists have
affectionately called our current generation the anxious generation. We've
got so many voices, so many posts, so many influencers, expectations,
pressures, trying to tell us what matters, trying to tell us what that one
thing is. And this morning's text is an incredible picture from David of what
single minded devotion and trust in Christ looks like what it looks like in
practice and what the fruit of a life of devotion and trust looks like. I've
loved this song for a long time. And in fact, last summer is we're going through
the Psalms. I told Brandon, hey, next summer I want Psalm 16. But now after
living with it for the past several weeks, I see it is so much more rich
and deep than I ever knew. Just about every verse of this Psalm speaks of
some aspect of single mindedness. And it shines a spotlight over and over
again on that one thing. It's a prayer, but it is so different than the vast
majority of my prayers. When we look at it, you'll see that David makes one
four word request at the beginning. And then the rest of the song is David
praying to the Lord and at the same time preaching the good news to
himself over and over again. So look at verse one, look at David simple, yet
incredibly impactful request. Preserve me, oh God, for in you I take refuge.
His four word request. The only time he asks the Lord for something in this
passage is preserve me, oh God. Other translations say, keep me safe or
protect me. The Hebrew word literally means to keep, to watch over, to guard.
David is asking the Lord to protect him and keep him safe because he, the
Lord is his refuge. That's an active trusting. That's an act of David's
will, a choice to look at the Lord, to look to the Lord for safety. Why?
It's not because there aren't competing options for David. And we'll see a
little bit more of that here in a minute. But why and how can David
confidently ask the Lord for his help and then confidently state that the
Lord is his refuge? We'll look at verse two. I say to the Lord, you are my
Lord. I have no good apart from you.
Because David knows he is experienced. He looks back on his life up until now.
And he looks at his present reality and he knows and says, you are my Lord.
You are Adonai. You have supreme sovereignty, absolute authority. And I
have no good apart from you.
No good. Everything in my life that is good is because of you. Or as James
tells us in verse 17 of chapter one, every good gift and every perfect
gift is from above coming down from the Father of lights. Nothing good in your
life, nothing good in my life is the result of anything other than being a
good gift from our good, sovereign, heavenly Father who loves you. It's
not a result of our work. So we can't boast. And David knows that he
banks on it. In the next two verses, we're going to see where David
contrasts two different groups of people, which at first, as you just kind of
read through it, it seems kind of odd. Why are we talking about these two
groups? But as we dig in a little, it fits perfectly to what David's talking
about. Look at verse three. As for the saints in the land, they are the
excellent ones in whom is all my delight. David's delight is in the saints in
the land, the household of God. That's a key part of David's single minded
devotion to the Lord. This highlights one of the greatest benefits of knowing
Christ is that we are part of the family of God. As we saw when we went
through the book of Ephesians together as a church, chapter two, verse 19 says,
So then you are no longer strangers and aliens, but you are fellow citizens
with the saints and members of the household of God built on the
foundation of the apostles and prophets. Christ Jesus himself being the
cornerstone in whom the whole structure being joined together grows
into a holy temple in the Lord. In him, you also are being built together
into a dwelling place for God by the Spirit. That's us, the body of Christ,
the church. That's community. That's why we do home groups. That's one of the
reasons why we're so excited to be entering into the covenant membership
process, because it's often through and with fellow believers that
the Lord preserves us. We find refuge together as one body. And so we see
David talking about the saints in the land, you know, how he delights in them,
the household of God. But then we look at verse four and we see him talk about
another group. The sorrows of those who run after another God shall multiply
their drink offerings of blood. I will not pour out or take their names on
my lips. David contrasts the saints in the land with those who are running
after other gods, sacrificing the idols. And you see it talks about the
sorrows of those. That word sorrows means so much more. It literally means
pain, nuisance or worry. In fact, other translations say those who run
after other gods will suffer more and more or troubles multiply for
those who chase after other gods. And David graphically describes their pagan
practices. He talks about their drink offerings of blood and it's easy as we
read this to almost skim over that part. I'm not an idol worshiper. I don't
sacrifice to other gods. But do I? I think it's wise to pause here and ask
ourselves what occupies my mind? What dominates my thoughts? Where is my
focus and passion? Maybe we could even ask, what's the root of my
nuisance or worry or anxiety? Are there things or people or desires I've
elevated to the throne in my life? Maybe it's control. Maybe it's
comfort, my ego or my reputation. Is it my kingdom come? My will be done? And so
it's been very instructive for me to look at what happens when my comfort
is threatened. So to look at what happens when I feel like I don't have
control or I'm not getting my way. Does it immediately lead to worry,
nuisance or anxiety? That's a good indicator for me that I might be
running after another God, an idol. And David is so single-mindedly devoted to
the Lord that he won't even take the names of those idols on his lips. And so
I have to ask what would that kind of radical devotion look like for us? How
do we get there? Again, it's David's single-minded focus on the Lord and his
goodness. Look at verses five and six. The Lord is my chosen portion in my cup.
You hold my lot. The lines have fallen for me in pleasant places. Indeed, I
have a beautiful inheritance. The Lord is David's portion in cup. And that
language, that's almost like the language of food and drink. He's saying,
the Lord is all I need. He's all I need. And do we believe that? Is the Lord
all you need? Do we recognize God's sovereign, all-wise, all-loving hand
holding our lot and establishing our boundary lines? That's the reality that
God has you right where you are. He's established your boundary lines on
purpose for a reason that maybe only he knows that reason right now. Even in the
difficult situations, the ones that don't make sense, the Lord has established
your lines. I love what Christian philosopher Dallas Willard says about
this topic. He said, God has yet to bless anyone except where they actually
are. And if we faithlessly discard situation after situation, moment after
moment is not being right, we will simply have no place to receive his
kingdom into our life. For those situations and moments are our life. And
David's joy is not first and foremost in God's gifts or his blessings, but in
the Lord himself, he is all David needs. And it's the same thing that the Lord said
to Aaron back in Numbers chapter 18, you shall have no inheritance in their
land. Neither shall you have any portion among them. I am your portion and your
inheritance among the people of Israel. If you are a follower of Jesus, you
indeed have a beautiful inheritance now and for eternity. And so David continues
on in verse seven, blessing the Lord, praising him for his counsel. Look at
how that's worded. I bless the Lord who gives me counsel. In the night also my
heart instructs me. The Lord gives David counsel and at night David's heart
instructs him. The Lord is gently speaking to David through his own heart.
Even at night when he's alone, potentially feeling threatened or scared, but he
trusts the Lord is working and counseling and instructing him. And so I
have to naturally ask why and how. How is David so sure of that? How can he
know and trust that it's the Lord instructing his heart? Because I've been
there so many times that I question is, is this my own mind? Is this my own
thoughts? Is this my own heart or is this the Lord? And that's what leads to
verse eight. I think that's what answers it. This is this is to me the
lynchpin, if you will, of the entire passage. This is the one thing. This
is the key to David's single minded focus and devotion. I have set the Lord
always before me because he is at my right hand. I shall not be shaken. I
have set the Lord always before me. And I think it's equally important for us
to see what David didn't say. It's not. I glanced at the Lord as I was
heading out to work. I gave him a quick 10 or 15 minutes before tackling my
agenda for the day. No, I set him always before me. I am intently looking
at dwelling on and fixated with the person and work of Jesus Christ. That's
what goes back to that confidence that he's instructing me because I'm
fixated on him. The fact I'm fixated on his work, the fact that while I was
dead in my trespasses and sin, dead and hopeless, because of his mercy and
great love for me, he made me alive in Christ. That's from Ephesians two or
the fact that Jesus, sinless and perfect and righteous became sin so I
could become the righteousness of God. Second Corinthians five. Setting the
Lord always before me means I am fixated on those truths. I am focused over and
over again on the person and work of Jesus Christ. And that reminds me of
many years ago. I got a Harley Davidson. Jennifer and I like to ride. We
sold it around the time Isaac was born. And I had grown up riding dirt
bikes. So I knew how to ride a motorcycle. But it had been a while. So I
thought it'd be wise to take a motorcycle safety class. It also helped with
the insurance. So it was kind of a double win. But part of that class, they
talked about the concept of target fixation. And the whole idea there
is as you're riding the motorcycle, you're going down the street. If you
suddenly see an object in the road, whether it's a huge rock, a pothole,
maybe a big bump in the road, you don't look at that. You look at where you
want the motorcycle to go. If you're coming around a curve and maybe you're
a little too fast, you don't panic. You look to the end of the curve and your
motorcycle is naturally going to take you there. Why is that? Because on
motorcycles, as in life, we naturally gravitate toward. We move in the
direction of what we're looking at, of what we're fixated on. So I ask, what
what do you find yourself looking at and dwelling on? Is it your sin? Is it
the struggle that I just can't get off my mind? And so I'm constantly
thinking about how do I overcome it? How do I battle it? What am I going
to do? And I'm putting all my focus and attention on that. Maybe it's
a struggle or maybe it's control. Maybe it's my agenda, my future. What if we
were to follow David's lead? I said the Lord always before me. Jesus put it
like this in Matthew six, but seek first the kingdom of God and his
righteousness and all these things will be added to you. All what things?
What we're going to eat, what we're going to wear, where we're going to live, our
job, our kids, our safety, our security, all the things that that can become idols
for me or those small G gods, all of those things that I can tend to put
my focus and effort and attention and fixation on. He's saying, seek me
first, fixate on me and I'm going to provide the answers to all of these.
We're saying as in verse four, I'm not going to pour out these drink offerings
of blood to these things. I'm not going to take them on my lips. I'm not
going to focus on them. I'm going to seek Jesus and his kingdom and his
righteousness. First, I will set the Lord always before me and trust as he
counsels me as he instructs my heart. And as in verse eight, he says, I shall
not be shaken. We all know what it means to be shaken. That that panic
feeling. The what ifs. What about this? What will I do if this happens? As I
heard someone say recently, instead of focusing on what if I'm going to focus
on if God, if God is for us, who can be against us. He who did not spare
his own son, but gave him up for us. How will he not also with him
graciously give us all things? And because of that, we will not be shaken.
You see that that shake avoidance, the absence of shaking. That's not from our
circumstances. It's not from a new job, a new relationship, control of our
finances, control of our kids. The absence of that shake, the shake
avoidance is directly tied to setting the Lord always before me. And we see
the fruit of not being shaken in verses nine and 10 rejoicing and security.
Therefore my heart is glad and my whole being rejoices. My flesh also
dwells secure for you will not abandon my soul to shield or let your
Holy One see corruption. Because of everything David just prayed, because
of all those truths, because he knows he is not shaken. David rejoices, because
he knows he is secure in the Lord. David secure in the here and now, because
he hopes in the Lord, because the Lord is always before him. But he also
knows because of the Lord, he is secure for eternity. The Lord will not
abandon him in the grave. He knows his future is secure. And while David,
David didn't have the same benefit we do of knowing fully about Jesus and
about the cross and about the resurrection. David is so confident in
the promises of God that he knows his future is secure. And at the same
time, he is speaking prophetically about Jesus. See, David died and his body
still lies corrupted in the grave. He's still in the tomb. Christ, however,
was raised on the third day after his death. Listen to this from Peter's
sermon at Pentecost from Acts two. This Jesus delivered up according to
the definite plan and foreknowledge of God, you crucified and killed by the
hands of lawless men. God raised him up, loosing the pangs of death, because
it was not possible for him to be held by it. For David says concerning
him, I saw the Lord always before me, for he is at my right hand that I
may not be shaken. Therefore my heart was glad and my tongue rejoiced. My
flesh also will dwell in hope, for you will not abandon my soul to Hades or let
your Holy One see corruption. You have made known to me the paths of life. You
will make me full of gladness with your presence. Brothers, I may say to you
with confidence about the patriarch David that he both died and was
buried. And his tomb is with us to this day, being therefore a prophet
and knowing that God had sworn with an oath to him that he would set
one of his descendants on the throne. He foresaw and spoke about the
resurrection of Christ, that he was not abandoned to Hades, nor did his flesh
see corruption. This Jesus God raised up and of that we are all witnesses
being therefore exalted at the right hand of God and having received from
the Father the promises of the Holy Spirit. He has poured out this that
you yourselves are seeing and hearing. And that is our ultimate hope. We can
be secure and unshaken in the here and now, but so much more if we are
followers of Jesus, we are secure for eternity. That's our hope. That is
cause for worship. That is cause for rejoicing, for knowing we dwell
secure. And so finally, as we wrap up, look at verse 11. You make known to me
the path of life in your presence. There is fullness of joy at your right hand
or pleasures forevermore. That's it. Once again, the one thing. Isn't that
what all people are looking for, searching for life, joy and pleasures?
Isn't that the root of what causes our anxiety, our worry and stress? It's our
pursuit of life, joy and pleasure. And the one thing is all of those are
found in the presence of the Lord. We'll experience that by setting the
Lord always before us, trusting him to be our refuge, recognizing he is the
source of all good things. We have no good apart from him, hoping in his
sovereign placement of us right here, right now for such a time as this, and
then rejoicing that because of his presence in our lives, we don't have
to be shaken. As we prepare to pray and then worship, let me ask you, where is
your true hope? What or who is always set before you? Is it is it like me
sometimes your control or your security or your plan or your agenda or your
future? Or is it the person and finished work of Jesus? Are there things, maybe
people, circumstances that you've elevated to or chased after as another God? If
that's the case, as it is for me so often, this is the perfect opportunity
for repentance, to just simply turn your eyes back to Jesus, to set him always
before you. Let's pray. Father, we do thank you for the person and work of Jesus,
who as we talked about was sinless and yet became sin for us and the hope that
is found in us just focusing on, turning our eyes towards fixating on that very
truth. So let this time not be just mere singing. Let this be a time of gazing, of
beholding the beautiful riches of Jesus. And I ask that you would pinpoint in
each of our lives those things that maybe we have elevated to a place and
that you would just give us freedom to say, Jesus, I give this to you. Turn my
eyes towards Jesus. Help me to gaze upon the beauty. And in that and through that,
we pray that Jesus will be glorified in Jesus name I pray. Amen.